have you really considered I mean I'm
every interview that that you're doing
right now to promote proven innocent
is also I feel like they're tackling on
do Frazier stuff and any idea that
you're oh yeah James Corden that you
guys are meeting with writers and yeah
there's volleying about ideas to to
bring back for yeah there's like a
double you know layup first for the
Fraser idea we've been kicking it around
I'm also kicking around but the idea of
another sitcom with a really well-known
actor is very famous who I mean I think
it's kind of a slam dunk that will sell
this show so I mean there's another
couple of shows I just can't talk about
it yet Alan Alda it would well there's
it it starts with an a but but so the
idea really will be I hope to do that
show and do an additional Frazier's
series on streaming like Netflix or
because it cuz they've got it you know
they they Fraser is still isn't like the
top ten on Netflix right in and out and
you interesting wow that's amazing and
so it it's likely that that's kind of
where its new home would be that's where
people are still watching and we're just
talking about they were talking about
doing a Breaking Bad movie and they're
putting it on Netflix because right so
it's like a little extra piece of
material or yeah yeah one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app